my talk of the table it's a big
announcement too this is from Michelle
Obama it's her latest project and you're
hearing it here first on CBS mornings we
like when that happens the former first
lady is launching Michelle Obama the
light podcast this is the first of eight
weekly episodes will be available on
Audible on Tuesday March 7th so that's
coming up soon the podcast really came
out of Mrs Obama's book tour for her
second bestseller it's called the light
we carry overcoming in uncertain times
that book is still flying off the
shelves look at that picture of Michelle
Obama could you put that picture back
just a second during that six City Tour
look at her during that six City Tour
she sat down with friends like Ellen
DeGeneres Tyler Perry Oprah David
Letterman Tracy Ellis Ross
I wasn't going to say me but I couldn't
believe Philadelphia it was a great
conversation we had a great time sold
out everywhere she went everybody shared
personal stories about topics like
relationships issues connected to race
gender and visibility adapting to change
the importance of lighting up for others
now it's there for everyone to hear on
Michelle Obama the light podcast I love
the title of the book too the light we
carry because she believes Mrs Obama
believes that all of us carry a light
even though you may not know it
everybody carries a light her husband of
course was the man in the Forefront but
when you sit down and you listen to her
I saw her in conversation with Oprah in
Brooklyn remember yes I do remember the
woman exudes a light about her and there
is a wisdom to her that if you sit and
listen I'm telling you it's something to
hear David Beck no you ain't wrong just
my opinion that's why every four years
there's a draft Michelle yes for
president
she's very firm no thank you no thank
you she is booked and busy she is